just one year ago robin hood was the
up-and-coming mobile brokerage that
millennials and retail traders couldn't
get enough of robinhood's total user
count was searching it in the millions
as the users got addicted to robinhood's
phenomenal ui and their gamification of
investing ever since the gamestop fiasco
and the collapse of dogecoin though
robin hood has struggled to maintain the
excitement or even maintain a positive
public opinion in fact so many people
left terrible reviews on the app store
and a play store following the gamestop
situation that robinhood's rating fell
to just one star at one point and the
google had to bail out robin hood by
removing reviews that quote-unquote
violated google's policies to make
things worse robin hood has been
consistently losing hundreds of millions
of dollars every single quarter forcing
them to constantly raise money these
worries were finally supposed to subside
with their ipo last year but the ipo has
only made things worse as it's made it
crystal clear that the market doesn't
like robinhood at all right now since
their peak in august right after their
ipo robinhood stock has fallen 85 which
correlates to a market cap loss of 56
billion dollars within just a matter of
six months this is actually super ironic
given that their current market cap is
nearly equivalent to their cash reserves
meaning that the market is giving
robinhood's business itself very little
credit so what happened to robin hood
and can they recover from this nightmare
taking a look back the story of robin
hood dates back to 2011 at the height of
occupy wall street if you're not
familiar with this movement it was
basically a protest against wall street
bailouts following the 2008 financial
recession at the time two college
friends named vlad tenev and baiji bot
had classic jobs on wall street these
guys were immigrants from bulgaria and
india respectively and had met at
stanford initially neither of them had
any problems or concerns with their
careers they were quickly moving up the
corporate ladder and likely earning fat
salaries but all this changed during
occupy wall street when one of their
mutual friends accused them of
profiteering from an unequal system the
duo didn't instantly quit their jobs or
anything but this statement stuck with
them and they started looking for ways
in which they could bridge the gap
between retail investors and wall street
one of the most obvious disparities they
stumbled upon were the lofty fees and
large minimum deposits required by most
brokerages now the fees weren't actually
that bad in nominal terms given that it
was just 50 cents or a dollar per share
or per option that you purchased but
from the back end it only cost pennies
to execute each of these trades so
brokerages were enjoying massive profit
margins combine this with the rise of
free-to-use games and apps like clash of
clans and facebook and it was clear to
vlad and baiju that they should create a
free to use brokerage to match the
underlying mission of the company they
selected the name robinhood which is of
course a reference to the disney
character that steals from the rich and
the gifts to the poor aside from free
trades and no minimum balance the dual
placed a massive emphasis on the app's
ui if the app was going to appeal to
regular people it better be easy to
navigate baiju says that his goal with
the app design was to make it quote dead
simple every time he came up with a new
feature or design he'd run over to
stanford from silicon valley to have
random college students test out the
future not only did this allow baiju to
develop an intuitive app but an app that
was fun to use you got confetti whenever
you bought new stocks and the buys you
paired this with clever vibrations and
haptic feedback that kept users engaged
robin hood would later face charges for
gamifying investments but this was great
for appealing to and retaining new users
and with that the duo was ready to
launch
robinhood while robin or dui was
phenomenal the key to actually
succeeding in the app market is
marketing whether that be organic or
paid baiju and vlad couldn't pay for
much marketing due to their limited
capital so they decided to spark
interest to another medium at
exclusivity people who wanted to use
robinhood were placed on a waiting list
and they could move up on the waiting
list by referring friends and the family
to robinhood not only did this make the
original launch easier to handle from
the back end thanks to a limited user
count but it gave people who made it
through the cut exclusivity which is
extremely powerful naturally as humans
we crave exclusivity because it gives us
a sense of belonging and importance as
well as a certain level of social clout
every luxury company out there leverages
this instinct to the max but likely the
best example of this within the tech
world is gmail back in 2004 when gmail
was launched google was the small player
going against giants like microsoft and
yahoo plus they had limited
infrastructure so they made a gmail
invite only and this is how it was till
2007. clearly this worked out extremely
well for gmail and the same could be
said about robinhood following their
initial launch in 2013 they were able to
build up a waiting list of 50 000 people
and by the time they launched on the
apple app store this number had
ballooned to 1 million people this
massive user interest allowed robinhood
to raise tens of millions from venture
capitalists and start investing in new
features and marketing in 2018 for
example they started rolling out the
infamous robin crypto and in late 2019
they launched fractional shares the new
funding also allowed them to start their
famous free stock referral program that
basically every finance youtuber has
milked to death in the meantime robin
hood was also upgrading their backend
infrastructure as well in late 2018 for
instance they started to self-clear
their orders all these new features made
robinhood more and more established
within the brokerage industry and that's
when the pandemic hit and the stock
market crashed generally this would be a
terrible time for brokerages but a lot
of retail traders were actually looking
to buy the crash combine this with
pop-up house money printer and it didn't
take long for stocks to recover and this
time tens of millions of retail traders
were on board it looked like things
couldn't get any better for robin hood
but in the background there were
actually several red flags
likely the biggest red flag surrounding
robin hood was the revenue model while
they weren't directly charging users for
trades they were charging users from the
backend through something called a
payment for order flow similar to google
and facebook collecting information on
our browsing habits and selling the data
to advertisers robinhood was collecting
all of our trades and selling them to
wall street firms called market makers
now robin hood didn't actually invent
this revenue model low-cost brokerages
like e-trade have been leveraging
payment for order flow for years but
this doesn't mean that it's a good
strategy payment for order flow is not
only heavily frowned upon but actually
illegal in several countries including
the uk canada and australia but wait a
minute what's the problem with payment
for order flow in the first place it
gives us basically unlimited free trades
right well the truth is it's not
actually free you're just charged
indirectly market makers aren't idiots
to pay for our emotional day trades and
hype investments they're paying for the
order flow to flip our orders and make a
profit for example let's say you're
willing to buy one share of apple for
100
if this order executes that means the
market maker was able to find someone
that was willing to sell one share of
apple for 99.50 or even 99
this gives the market maker 50 cents or
one dollar worth of profit which they'll
split with robinhood the difference
between how much you're willing to pay
and how much the seller is going to sell
for is called a bid ask spread and
market makers have been leveraging such
disparities for decades usually this
isn't a problem because market makers
only make a penny or two from each share
but given that market makers working
with robin hood have to split their
profits with robin hood their bid-ask
spreads are generally way larger in fact
the wall street journal found that
robin's spreads were as much as 60 times
larger than charles schwab so with the
robin hood sure you don't have to pay 50
cents for every share you purchase up
front but you're constantly overpaying
for every share you purchase which
indirectly charges you around the same
amount if not more and to make things
worse with traditional brokerages since
you're paying the fee you're the
customer and you're the top priority for
the brokerage but with robinhood since
the market makers are the ones that are
technically paying the fees even though
you're the one being charged for it
market makers are the customer and
they're the top priority
robin hood's broken revenue model would
eventually come back to haunt them but
in the late 2010s they had much bigger
issues to address in july of 2019 for
example robin hood admitted that they
were throwing the user's passwords in a
readable form across their servers which
had made it easy for hackers to steal
passwords and subsequently steal money
from these accounts similarly just a few
months ago robinhood confirmed that a
voice phishing scheme allowed hackers to
steal the email addresses of 5 million
customers and the full names of 2
million customers aside from these
security breaches a couple of wall
street bets users had found a glitch
within robinhood that allowed them to
borrow an infinite amount of money the
glitch entailed purchasing shares on
margin and then selling covered calls on
these shares users could then use the
proceeds from selling covered calls to
purchase more stock and sell more
covered calls on these newly purchased
shares and the cycle continues many wall
street bets users used this glitch to
engage in extremely risky trading which
resulted in many accounts sustaining six
figure losses and when all the fun was
over robin hood was the one that had to
pay the bill but none of these issues
hold a candle to the pr nightmare that
followed the suicide of alexander kearns
alexander was a university of nebraska
student that had been margin trading on
robinhood this wasn't going too well
though and at one point robinhood said
that his account balance was negative
730 thousand dollars after seeing this
alexander took his own life and on a
suicide note he accused robin hood of
allowing him to take on too much risk
the worst part about this was that the
negative 730 000 account balance wasn't
even legitimate it was a temporary
settlement glitch that would have
resolved by itself as you would guess
this led to several lawsuits regarding
gamification and risk disclosures many
of which are still ongoing but all these
lawsuits were just a sneak peek into
what would follow after the gamestop
fiasco
by now i'm sure all of y'all are
familiar with what happened with
gamestop wall street bets identified a
massive short interest in gamestop and
proceeded to buy heavily into the stock
it's not clear if this actually resulted
in a short squeeze or not but the hype
and momentum itself took gamestop to the
moon and robin hood was at the center of
this movement when things started
getting spicy though robin hood
restricted users from purchasing
gamestop and other short stocks their
official reasoning for this was that the
stocks were getting too volatile and
that they were trying to protect their
users from massive losses but given
their history with risk this was rather
hard to believe and suspicions went
elsewhere one of robinhood's biggest
market maker customers is a company
called citadel which also happened to
have a major short position in gamestop
now this isn't confirmed but it seems
like robin hood was pressured by citadel
to halt trading on gamestop and fearful
of losing one of their biggest customers
robinhood complied this is the problem
with their customers and users being
different people this trading halt was
followed up by dozens of class action
lawsuits but this was the least of
robin's problems whether the speculation
around robner's actions is true or not
the incident destroyed their reputation
as the broker of the people and the user
goat has suffered ever since despite
this poor outlook robin hood would
actually experience one last hurrah
accidentally in march april and may of
2021 dogecoin would rock it from just a
few cents up to 73 cents and given that
you could buy dogecoin on robin hood
this gave robinhood one more spectacular
quarter but after elon's appearance on
saturday night live dogecoin fell off a
cliff and sorted robinhood and robin
hood's initially hyped ipo ended up
being a massive bust
in terms of robinhood's short-term
future it's really not looking that
great
sentiment surrounding robin hood is
still as bad as ever and it's going to
be nearly impossible to beat the revenue
numbers from last year which largely
benefited from gamestop and dogecoin
fortunately robinhood has billions in
the bank and can weather a few painful
quarters or even a few painful years
maybe in the long term robin hood's
phenomenal ui will end up shining
through to retail investors but we'll
just have to wait and see at the end of
the day while robinhood did several
things right it seems like their entire
mission was a bit misguided you see i
don't think people hate wall street
because of high fees or prices i think
people hate wall street due to their
lack of transparency and accountability
so the key wasn't open a free brokerage
but rather open a transparent and
accountable brokerage this is one of the
main reasons that vanguard is so highly
respected vanguard doesn't have
shareholders or customers that are
different from their users so vanguard's
interests are always aligned with their
users porting this business model to
mobile devices paired with a tremendous
ui is what i think robin hood should
have done but instead they've become the
epitome of wall street the exact thing
that they were trying to find would you
prefer to use a brokerage with upfront
fees or a brokerage with back-end fees
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're glad that robinhood got a
taste of their own medicine and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]